- 哈嘍哈嘍
大家上線的話幫我打個1喔
然後聲音正常幫我打個2
好那我們就是等大家陸續上線的話
我們今天就是會去講到
一兆元交易量誤出的真理喔
那這個的話
這個的話是來自於就是
小周在上周日的話的話
參加了一個非常跨世紀的一個
一個講座
就是所謂的我們的
在市場上的大神巨人節
然後他在
辦了一個分享會
他是我是交易員
他是很少出來分享的
所以說
市場吃盛機會非常難得
那時候票好像是
現場三千人是
一下就秒殺了
那時候小優雖然沒搶到
但是
就是也很感興我們的
我的朋友大幣這邊的話
他就是他有那個
朋友票
然後就讓了一個票給我
所以我就可以去
也可以參加這個
這場盛會
好
那我們大家陸續上線的話
幫我打個
1跟2
真正常嘛
OKOK
好
那
那我們就是說
今天這場講座就是
只要講到就是
巨人節它其實它有一個
我是交易員的那個講座
它的主題其實叫做
對
那時候它主題叫做
一兆元的交易心法
那
因為它也是在台股上面
就是所謂的
從
一開始的當沖 一直做到波段 一直做到各種事件交易 做到海外期貨
都是非常傑出的一個短線的交易人 然後他在這五年是轉到中長線
好 所以就是
呃
這在講到說 在他交易過這麼久的這個時間裡面對不對
他悟出了什麼樣的真理 然後呢 他在這場講說你也有提到
領先市場的秘密 就是你看到的資訊值多少錢 那這個話也蠻值得玩味的
所以小時候會一一來跟大家做介紹
好 那我們就直接就開始
好 那
那這是那時候1月11號的那個
我是教育員的巨人節的講座
在台北的國際的會議中心
那現場是3000人也是爆滿
好 那這就是那個時候我們在那個
門口的話就是跟我們那個
野教育的夥伴拍照的
就是在我是教育員這邊
那這本左邊其實原本是他的流程安排
就是所謂的
有他原本
呃
一開始他講的那一部分
然後有個中場表演
然後再有個沙發座談
還有觀眾的QA
那那時候的話其實
小時候第一時間知道的時候就有朋友就跟小時候分享說
這場講座
創下了一個財經講座的一個高度
等一下小時候會慢慢的跟大家說明
第一個就是
他
請到了
兩個中央級人物來參加這個講座
那當然也包括他有邀請他的一些
就是市場上比他更活躍的一些教育人在場下
那市場主席蠻特別的就是說
他請到了中場表演請到了周湯豪來做表演
那這也是蠻特別的
因為我覺得一去年節他那時候他講了一句話
他說他很感謝大家來到現場聽他的講座
那他帶來很多他的教育心法給大家治癒
他也希望他喜歡的音樂可以去分享給大家
那其實算是
嗯
蠻
這高度真的蠻高的
呵呵
就是讓我想說想到說
那我有一天我飯
我可能也要請五月一天了
呵呵
是要請五很多人
他說他好像是一個人而已
可是我覺得這是已經創下了
財經獎座的第一個高度
就是他把
他所想要聽的音樂歌手請到現場
然後呢
他在沙發照台的時候是
選擇跟
酒面
跟他做一個podcast的一個對談
那酒面算是台灣的
嗯
蠻出名的百萬的youtuber
好
那
那如果是來到這頻道裡面的話
還沒有知道小周的話
小周自己本身是全職的交易人
那我目前是在群衣期貨服務
那我們是放過大家小小的獎座
然後我們也拿過大家小小的獎盃
我也是單槍大學選擇權的獎師
然後呢
在2023年的話小周也有上台受邀我們群衣的比賽的報仇王的頒獎
那我們這是我們VIP的頒獎的典禮
好
那這個就是當天的那個現況
就是所謂的
那時候我是票師在五樓啦
你可以看到說就很像那個演唱會規格對不對
就是現場是滿滿都是人喔
然後就是左右都有一個大螢幕
然後上面也有一個
然後就是一個大舞台在這邊
那這就是一開始他講到說
我是教育員一兆元的教育心法
那他講到很多交易的本質
但是說他雖然也有提到一些產業面的東西
但是我小時候覺得啊
就是產業面的東西的話是
每個人都有各種專精嘛
但是我覺得值得學習的是
一個成功成為市場上頂尖交易人
他怎麼去思考策略這件事情
怎麼去思考市場這件事情
那我覺得他也不常思的講了很多的關鍵的細節
那小周會去就他講的細節裡面
去用小周的方式來跟大家做說明
當然可能觀點不一定是跟據人覺得雷同
但是我想藉由這個機會讓大家了解到
其實不管是小周阿還是Alumi 還是Goboda等等的
其實大家在講的東西其實都會有一個雷同的地方
你可以知道說這些贏家的交易人都是在關注在什麼東西上面
好 那因為中場的表演是周湯好
那就是周湯好還有去祝福現場的大家
然後那小周的話就是把這段也是等一下播放給大家
那希望小周湯好的祝福的話也給現場
現在有聽到直播或是我們的事後影音的一些朋友們
如果有什麼發財的table可以在台戲區舉我
我也想知道
大家這邊
2020的
剛開始的2020
所以希望今年能祝大家一些
都很順利
祝大家平安
祝大家介紹
然後當然祝大家發財
我們應該要去到這邊就說
多當好
祝大家發財
來自於周湯豪對大家的祝福
好 那在下半段的話就是他是跟九面做一個
沙發隊團的Podcast
就是所謂的 就是有點像是一個
那個 九面講的都是奢華Podcast
因為他們中場表演是周湯豪
好 那我們就來今天的主題
那當然說
就是因為他
巨人節他有放一些限動的
講座的影音嘛
的片段
但是因為就是盤權問題啊
所以就是大家可以去掃這個line
然後輸入114
我會再把那個
就人節IG的限動的一個影片給大家
好
那
一開始我們講到今天的正題就是說
他交易的一兆元
好
那在一兆元是什麼樣的概念
其實他是近五年來的成交額
只有近期五年來
所以說他其實以前做當充的時候是更多的
好
這邊的話
他其實他的交易稅跟手續費加起來大概是快九億
那為什麼要付出九億的成本
他說很關鍵的原因很簡單
期望值是真的
所以這也是小時候常跟他講的
你在做交易的時候
其實你要去注意你的期望值
那期望值是什麼東西組成的
就是勝率跟盈虧比
所以說基本上你賺錢一次賺多少
虧錢一次虧多少
跟你的在各個策略上面的勝率
你是要去做統計的
等於是不管是自由人
包括巨人節
包括市場上所有的成功交易人
都會很專注在期望值是正這件事情
如果期望值還不是正的時候的話
那你就會知道說你有哪些地方需要修正
所以說對他來講
奇妄值只知道是正的
他根本不需要去在意這些成本
因為奇妄值正的情況下
他只要是反覆不停的用同樣的邏輯做做交易
他就可以去把他的獲利擴大了
所以他就說這是一門生意
經過計換的生意
那他一開始就只有自我介紹
他說他從17歲進入股市
至今15個年頭
所以他就帶來的
正確的交易的心態
找尋策略的方向
跟介紹重要的交易的邏輯
這幾個部分
好
那
其實他有提到說市場上沒有爵士武功
因為他講到說
市場上可能很多人在追求一個無敵的指標
或者是一個無敵的參數
只是呢
在大家交易過一段時間完之後
你會知道說其實
我們跟大戶的距離沒有很近
重點只是在經驗跟邏輯
好
所以其實大眾的幻想都是幻想出
有無腦的密碼
就是一道
無腦的招數
可是在紀人節的眼中
他覺得
並沒有所謂無腦這件事情
那
他反而覺得說
其實交易策略很多時候啊
是源自於自己的生活觀察跟邏輯推演
那他也是蠻慷慨的在現場做了一次推演
所以其實
真正的優勢不是在秘密的參數
而是說你可以把簡單的日常觀察轉化成策略
這也是他講到就是說
市場上其實很多新聞啊
或者是很多大家
收到一些訊息
其實很多人都覺得說
好像比如說今天成交量破造了
今天那個台股成家上近期都破造了
然後一次七千億
就變成說
那這個東西到底跟交易有什麼關係
可能你會覺得
把它當成一個新聞看
然後它就結束了
但是呢
一個成功的交易人在每一個新聞
他會去背後去解讀這件事情
那他背後隱藏了什麼因子
那市場在什麼時候會認同這個新聞
都會去做一個沙盤推演
好
所以
這邊是講到說資訊的價值
就是說
這邊應該是先講到那個
就是說 所謂的
當你收到一些訊息的時候
你要去什麼解讀
所以說這訊息的時候就是
你這個訊息的價值到底是多少
其實說
不是說價值是多少
小時候想要下一個註解
就是說今天你收到一個訊息
其實大部分能收到一樣的訊息
除非你是比較領先的
之外
你要去理解到說
比如說今天有個利多
那
市場到底有沒有對這件事情反應
欸 如果
沒有反應 那是不是可以去關注未來
大家真的關注到這件事情的時候 行情會怎麼變變
或者是大家對這個新聞是沒有什麼感覺的
可是呢 像你講到說 近年來飆漲的記憶體
其實記憶體缺獲的一個題材在前年 應該算前年了
前年就已經發酵了 但是行情卷沒有發動
所以說其實它有點像是 你收到了一個颱風警報
但是呢 你還是要去確認氣象圖裡面你發現太平洋有颱風點的形成就是你必須去觀察到這個族群可能會發動但是你要去等到真正的深造去發生的時候
才會去執行你的策略
但是這就是所謂的來自於我們的生活
所以他居然覺得他覺得滿
幾個例子
他第一個例子他是講說歷史統計
好
他講說其實就是說有一個
大家統計滿多的嘛
就是所謂的可能就叫做新春開紅盤
什麼可能有八成以上
就是股票都是
新春開盤第一天都是開紅盤
但是呢
八成
那同樣一樣收到這個訊息
可能就覺得說
哦那他只是說就是過年很容易漲而已
那居然解後去怎麼去反思這個
這個資訊可以去什麼去引導到交易的部分
等於是他就是說
他就跟大家講說
你的手機裡面有沒有什麼自選
那個庫存或自選股
他說你就把你的庫存或自選股
可能大概50到60檔吧
你去一檔一檔去看
過去在1月到2月過年的期間
是不是跨過一個過年完之後
行情是上漲的
所以他說只需要用大概兩小時了
用肉眼去驗證就好了
從這點就可以發現到
其實到底有多少人其實不會去做這個統計
等於是說在交易這件事情上
如果你願意花時間去勤奮去研究
那你就知道你會去拉開跟別人的距離
好 那我這邊來看一下大家應該聲音都正常嘛
OKOK 好
OK 嘿嘿 好
OK 好
那 接著我們要講到說
他這邊講到
除了剛剛是一個所謂的歷史統計所營造的策略
第二個是事件驅動與邏輯推演
所以就是剛剛講到的
欸 市場爆量現在是一兆的成交量
那他第一時間想到什麼
第一時間想到的是
券商的手續費收入會暴增
所以說他覺得券商股應該會受惠
但是呢 在這個新聞出來
曾經這樣暴徵完之後
券商股並沒有漲
所以對他來講 他覺得在這個時間點
他去壓住券商股
對他來講 是一個零風險的邏輯獲利
為什麼 因為他說 如果未來是在市場上
大家意識到這件事情的時候
那券商股就會去 有更多人願意買進
那其實市場就這樣嘛
就是越多人願意買進 他就容易上漲
的時候,那他就可以去從中做一個佈局的獲利
但是其實現在行情還沒有發動
所以說,可是對他來講
因為券商股也沒有所謂的利空
所以等於是,如果說今天
這個一造成交流並沒有反應在券商股上面的時候
對他來講,就是把它賣掉了
也沒有所謂的太多的風險
因為他並沒有所謂的利空
所以他等於是說,在講說
當大眾在吃瓜看戲的時候
你一是一個成功成熟的交易員
你要去思考這場大戲裡面,絕對的受益著
所以說 像近年來很多啊
欸這是川普 他在講一些言論的時候
到底真正受惠的是哪一些產業跟哪一些類果
那就可以去從中裡面去找到一些交易的機會
那今天主要講到就是
他講到一個非常核心的一個點
也是小時候常常在交易的時候
去尋找 或者是跟我們的
客戶夥伴的話常常講
他講到說
其實所謂的供需失衡
就是所謂的獲利的機會
那我們先看一下
聲音應該都正長嘛
OK
好
Anderson家
晚安喔
福曹春晚安
阿倫晚安
好
那
這個東西他去Hooling到他其實另外一張投影片就是交易的本質就是供需
好
為什麼今天行情會上漲
就是所謂的結構性的供需跟需求不平衡
其實不管是
常常常有人會想說
小時候上股票為什麼會漲
欸 其實所謂的就是 為什麼會這樣
因為買進的人 願意追價買進
但是 股票發行量就是這些嘛
所以越多人越願意不計代價買進的時候 行情就會上漲
就是所謂的 需求大於攻擊的時候
好 那 這邊他舉的其中一個例子就是像是
欸 蠻簡單的 先從颱風天的蔬菜理論
他說 當今天颱風預報發布的時候
就是等於說 預計就是颱風要來了嘛
欸 可是是不是還沒來
還沒來的時候 這個時候
大家市場預期蔬菜的供給會減少
所謂的供給減少 那需求是不是不變嘛
所以供給減少 需求不變的情況下
菜價就會上漲
所以說今天這個高麗菜的上漲 價格會上漲
但是其實台方還沒來嘛 對不對
可是大家為了預防這件事情發生
他會先去買進
就很像機器在缺貨的時候一樣
缺貨的時候 缺貨是一個新聞嘛
缺貨是一個題材
但是真正缺貨真正需要到新的包案下來的時候
其實是還沒的
是有一個時間差的
可是市場上會先去反應這件事情
所以你可以去觀察到
不管是任何一個訊息
任何一個新聞出來的時候
到底相關的東西有沒有反應
市場有沒有預期這件事情會發生
假設市場預期這件事情發生
那就會股價就會有所變動
所以他說等到
他說你不會等到
就是這個消息都出來了
比如說像是說真的
真的消息都底定了
比如說財報都出來了
你才去說
喔 這時候才去做買進
而是所謂的
如果你預期這個財報
大家市場預期是比較好的
像那些台積電的
大家就預期財報會比較好
所以是不是在財報之前就有一波上漲
所以這等於是說
你需要一個所謂的商盤推援
你是必須對行情有一個想像力的
然後呢同時你要對這個行情有一個規劃
如果是這個樣子走的時候
行情會怎麼走
如果是這個狀況發生的時候
好
然後呢
在
第二個他講到就是所謂的
記憶體報價的異常
其實他那個時候他講到說
其實記憶體是什麼
在10點的時候會有一個
統一的市場報價
這個小時候也沒有特別研究
然後可是他講到說
他舉個例子
在10月底跟11月5號
11月10號
11月12的時候
他發覺就是所謂的
就是記憶體的價格一直在上漲
但是在11月12的時候突然出現了一個
比較小幅度的趨緩
所以他剛剛就說他看到這個狀況的時候他就知道說
那時候報價突然趨緩的時候
在那一天11點公佈
11點那個報價公佈的時候
從漲停下殺10%
所以就是從一個他觀察到一個資訊上面的一個價值
等於是說 它在這過程中透過一個從數據裡面去驅動股價的一個例子
那同樣的舉個例子
就是它說 就那時候突然崩跌是因為 你剛剛看到什麼意思
就是所謂的 剛剛原本的報價的上漲有趨緩
所以導致市場預期現在可能是個轉折
所以它就會變成是 大家就覺得 現在的記憶體既然沒有漲那麼
沒有漲勢沒有漲那麼兇了 那是不是代表著需求變少了
所以價格就會去往下跌
好 然後那時候他講到說
當大家都從11點這個時候去收到這個資訊的時候
他那個時候他去買了一個提前10分鐘的一個報價
那當然這是我覺得就是所謂的資訊的價值
那時候他也大家跟我們科普一下
他說 找10分鐘的這個記憶體的報價的這個
一年需要15萬
那就等於是他花了這個15萬去取得10.50的提前的報價
一樣在這個時候
他在報價完之後
剛剛不是趨緩完之後
第一體的報價又恢復繼續上漲的一個趨勢的時候
結果今天盤中在一些技術面的這些基本的消息
他是從跌停的時候
在10.50一公布打開反彈5%
所以他只要說
這個資訊的一個導致的引導的一個交易的方式
其實大家都知道
但是小周要想要想要這邊想要強調
不是說你要去追求領先別人的資訊
而是說當這個資訊你知道這種狀況會有在發生的時候
你要怎麼去規劃你的交易的策略
等於是他在這邊巨人節拿到了這樣子的一個記憶體的報價
所以他從中中去規劃一個交易的邏輯
就是說今天如果有所變化的時候行情會怎麼去發動
那這種狀況就是所謂的規劃策略的其中一個方式
所以說他講到說事件驅動
等於是像剛剛講到就是他是統計過去十年來春節的走勢
確認二月上漲容易跳空上漲
那他就去找他的庫存哪些會是容易上漲
那他就是執行過年前買進過年後賣出
所以他就花一個小時去檢討十年的數據
所以就等於是說在這個地方他的統計上面是
去看看什麼樣的消息跟策略
可以怎麼樣去衍生成交易的策略
那你可以怎麼去佈局
所以說他接著講到說
其實他說要放下對現行的執著
因為他覺得很多驅動因子
其實是基本面報價的數據的時候
其實數不夠是很愚蠢的新聞
他覺得看懂為什麼
那小周其實覺得這邊想像一個註解
不是說現行的執著
而是說當現行出現的時候
你不是執著在漲跌
而是你要去看透背後漲跌的原因
不管是在背後的人他是怎麼去想的
那他在那個地方他會去遭受到什麼樣的壓力
就像小時候想想講多空失衡的地方
為什麼有這些地方會突然出藏紅或藏黑
等於是當一面倒的行情出動發現的時候
那為什麼對方會投降
你可以去思考每一段行情的走勢
為什麼會有這樣子的背後的因子在
那去思考背後的邏輯
接著他講到說
其實他說小資
有人在問說
欸 唐人有人問他說
就是什麼從他之前的小資金做到現在的大資金
那因為他其實好像一開始買是30萬資金而已
然後現在到現在已經可能是百億了
那他講到匯數累積本金他是用當充
因為當充是所謂的
他本金是10萬年報酬率50%
也僅5萬 根本無法維生
他必須靠次數放大獲利絕對值
所以他說很多人可能在市場上
你可能去建議說 新手可能就建議做波段
但是 或者是小資俗就建議做波段
其實他覺得是有點謬誤的因為其實你個人因為資金小你必須用高周轉去把你的獲利擴大不然其實你追求報酬率你資金小的情況下追求報酬率其實是沒有任何意義的
就算你只有50萬好了
那就算是100%的報酬也才100萬而已
根本在可能一年這個過程中
你可能也過不了多久的生活
所以他說等他一開始用小資助的快速當中累積資本完之後
才去談你的資產配資
然後呢 在市場配色的情況下 你要去降低出手次數 抓住大趨勢
所以 它是經過大的時候 它會有一些流通性的風險
你去看準大波段才出手
所以它講到說 當充常被污名化 但是它是小資族翻身的唯一工具
前提是風暴比要守住
所以 小周真的是蠻 真是去年大學 是我的很大的偶像
因為 其實有時候 在市場上有一些人 誤會當充這件事情的時候
其實 小周其實有點像 我是因為 期貨因為交易
也有崭新不同的人生的時候
所以對我來講
期貨啊或是當充交易其實是
有點像是我的小朋友一樣
就是很怕...很...
擔心大家誤解他
可是又沒辦法被他辯解
所以我覺得巨人節身為我們當充界的始祖
那他就是所謂的
站出來為當充講這句話
其實小時候也是滿欣慰的
那他所謂的風暴比較少的原因是說
就是你不能說每次賺錢都賺很少
然後虧損很大
就所謂的你的風暴比不能是小賠
大賺小賠
應該不能是小賺大賠
那接著就是他講到就是說
就是大家都非常有
有那個想法就是想要知道的就是他怎麼去做到那麼大的
因為其實就是
一年賺錢、兩年賺錢、五年賺錢其實
在短期上面並不會很困難
但是能夠把私心擴大意思是
所有交易人的課題
所以他特別去講到這個議題
為什麼他敢擴大?他說他極端的風暴比
什麼
他講到說他一開始的時候
他在不確定的時候他會用小部位試單
等於是用小錢去買感覺
他聽說也比較不痛
但是他有自信的時候他就會去把部位全部壓進去
重點是
在獲利高
在順利還有把握的時候極大化獲利
所以他的鑽培比其實不是靠著爆波段
他的鑽培比拉大的原因是靠加碼
等於是他在試單的過程中沒感覺說
他就用很小的部位去做試單
然後在有把握行情走進去的時候開始做加碼
好
才會去極端的擴大他的賺賠比
所以他其實是用小單位去換取盤桿確認方向
然後獲利後加碼之後趨勢明確的時候
具有安全邊際的時候開始大部位的植物都壓進去
所以小部位的停損不會痛
可以允許更多次的嘗試
可是他說在這個你把資金擴大這個過程中
在這個過程中你會去面臨到一件事情
就是所謂的如果今天停損太小
你會去忽視它的話
它覺得會是一個你成長的痛點
它覺得會有一個心理的不退層
你必須重新定義痛苦跟麻木
等於說它其實會把很小的虧損
去把它當成世界末日去嚴重的糾正
其實我覺得這算是小時候家的註解
今天他每一筆交易他都很珍惜
每一次停損的機會
停損完之後他都不會去把它當成
可能錢很小他就不管他
而是每一筆當成很重要的去做檢討
那他說
當你對小賠敏感對大賺五感的時候
去訓練大賣
就所謂的
他說他賺到一百萬的時候
他覺得賺到一百萬的時候
他覺得就是也沒什麼
當你可以把賺到一百萬沒什麼
賺你賠一百塊錢都去認真的去檢討的時候
他覺得這種反人性的方式就可以去慢慢的訓練他把大錢當成小錢
然後去更能夠用平常心去看待行業
可是小周這邊下個註解
因為他後面也有提到就是說
他其實在操作上面的話
他其實不看庫存的
庫存的損益的
就是其實他覺得庫存的損益跟行情更沒有任何關係
所以等於是對損益不要去做太過執著
但是對每一筆交易的品質你會去更注重
所以他说每一笔每一分钱都是辛苦钱
就是说今天你对亏损无感的话
那你就可能会走入一个失败的一个窘境
就所谓你因为钱少然后就觉得也没差不管他
所以他会去在亏损这件事情上去
去试图去复盘
让自己不要白赔
那他说对亏损有痛感
这时候你可以逼自己修正
然后去优化自己的策略
所以他讲的一个注定就是
如果你對賠錢沒感覺
你就不會去找出你的策略的漏洞在哪邊
好
那接著他講到就是說
就是所謂的
行情其實跟我們的庫存無關
他只會
不好意思
舉個例子他說
今段行情上場完之後
如果你原本持有
結果他行情往下掉的時候
然後你去把它賣掉
然後你的心裡就會想說
喔 還好賣掉因為轉弱了嘛
可是
如果沒有在場上的人
可能在回檔的時候反而會覺得
想要去買進
終於回檔還想要去買進
然後呢 如果在高連買進的掉下來完之後
就會想說 哇 好像被套牢了 所以他就是會去攤平他
所以其實他說 每一段行情 每一個持有的人解讀這段行情都不一樣
但是實際上行情跟我們庫存是無關的
欸 小時候這邊會下個註解喔
其實金融交易上面的行情走勢就是所謂的背後的人性
當你去知道一段行情上漲的時候
這樣的這個世類的人 會怎麼去看待這個行情
會有怎麼樣的市場的共識
就會成為未來走勢的一個目標
所以一樣回到剛剛小周常講的
你去解讀45解讀市場
K棒走勢背後真正的原因
就是所謂的交易的本質
你就會去看到市場的真相
而不是你現在你的成本在哪邊
去導致你要不要出場的一個邏輯
好
所以他說其實交易像你講生意一樣
賣便當賣蔬菜也不一樣
你不用去找神奇的代表
開始尋找供需不平衡的位置
之後試圖在每一段行情裡面
你都去找到就說
喔 這個地方是失衡的時候才出趨勢嗎
那是什麼樣的新聞去驅動這樣的走勢
什麼樣的感覺 什麼樣的心態
所以說國安基金進場的時候
到底行情有沒有如預期 止跌
那如果是止跌我們可以怎麼做
然後呢
當今天行情突然有一個突然性的利空下跌的時候
可是這個利空到底市場會怎麼反應的
是短期嗎 還是長期
如果是短期的 那短期用買盤的時候
可能就是一個短期的底部
這樣子 好
OK
所以他講說就是交易事後驗屍
所以他講說
就是他賠100塊要去做檢討
檢討是什麼 檢討他幾個核心 小豆其實常常講的
就是所謂的 你的交易的財報嘛
你交易完之後你去減何 第一個
你這個禮單是虧損的完之後你去減何
是不是符合你的計畫
那你的出場是根據你的策略還是你的情緒的出場
就比如說你可能怕拉回所以你趕快急著出場
還是說你是覺得行情可能不對
但是你又想要等一等
就是所謂的情緒性的出場
然後他就去歸入音書說是誰賺走這筆錢
所以當你垂罐子有這筆錢的情況下
就等於是你去揣摩贏家的進出場邏輯
今天他在這個地方突然性的一個擊殺
他是想要做什麼樣的事情
那如果是洗盤 那什麼樣的位置
站回去 那你可以去再做一個下一個交易的規劃
那從此你可以去了解到這個商品的一個慣性
所以我剛剛講說 記憶體在11點的時候 可能會有一個報價的一個公布
說說美國在一些經濟數據 比如像昨天的CPI
是不是 公布完之後 美國就往上噴嘛
那等於是在這個時間點 你就可以知道說
這邊從事件驅動的一個行情走勢 是什麼原因
那 後續大家會怎麼看待這個數據
好 所以 那當然有 好像有人就問說
檢討的話 那叫什麼樣的檢討叫對的
那這個其實想說在 可能在
前幾年剛開始交易的時候也是常常問的
大家都在問說 自己做的對不對
其實交易並沒有所謂的對錯
所以他講到 檢討也沒有所謂的對錯
所以他去揣摩對手的進出 誰把我的錢賺走了
那他其實是沒有對錯的
只要你願意去做檢討
那你的教育系統就可以去得到一個優化
所以其實只要你願意檢討
你的能力就會去提升
所以他說
聚而獲利
為什麼他可以做到那麼大的秘密
就是他只在最有自信跟已經獲利的時候放大槓桿
就是所謂的
今天他看錯的時候是小部位去做試單
但是他在看對的時候
他會勇於去把部位壓大
但是這個加碼這個哲學我覺得算是
就是交易比較進階的一個部分
但是也是巨人節他講到的
我們每一個交易人勢必要去面對這件事情
就是所謂的你要去拉高你的賺賠比
只要靠加碼就可以極度性的拉高
那這過程中當然需要一個有趨勢的商品行情
那在這過程中就是他比起拉高勝率是
他覺得是簡單比較多的
那你要去透過大量的練習去了解到什麼時候你比較有把握
那當然像小時候比較喜歡打短衝的也是一樣啊
今天你交易過很大量的商品的時候
你會知道什麼時候特別有把握
那你就可以去慢慢掌握
你可以把握的這個盤去做攻擊就可以了
所以他就說
就是成功操板手其實有一個共通點
不是天賦
也不是什麼神奇的指標或是內線
他說是對邏輯的極致追求熱愛
他說每一個他看到的成功教練都是享受研究
而且他在交易是樂在其中的
其實小時候這一點也可以分享
就是說為了
其實交易有時候
很多時候是
你是去享受這個決策中的一個
系統化的一個優勢
跟一個決策下的一個快樂一個自由
等於是說在這過程中
交易是一件很快樂的一件事情
你找到一檔標股
你找到一檔趨勢去上車
然後去做加碼
那你去做獲利
如果你是看錯了 停損完之後
那你也去好奇一下
為什麼這個地方市場會有一個這樣的反應
等於是你要去樂在其中然後呢 持續做自我修正我覺得自我修正也很重要很多人是因為沒有做復盤那等於是只是享受中間的那個刺激跟快樂但是他卻沒有所謂的交易修正這件事情
如果你把交易修正做的事情
跟享受交易樂在其中
然後你去在研究上面你是很快樂的
那其實你離成功就不遠了
所以他說沒有什麼神奇的密碼
第一個
透過市場的一些數據跟資訊
透過一些想像力把這個訊息轉化成策略執行力
然後呢 去享受
每筆交易 然後去熱帶其中
所以 就是
總結一下 這他講的小語言的戰略情談
第一個
尋找供需不平衡的地方
然後去找尋背後的一個發生的因子
然後你去透過事件驅動跟各種的統計驅動
去看看有沒有交易的機會
然後他去追求極致的風暴比
而非高升率
他那時候他就靠加碼
去拉高他的極致的風暴比
然後小單試錯
他順勢他會去中一場
所以他另外講說
賠錢要覺得要痛
就是你不要覺得虧損少
就覺得沒有很重要
等於是說因為你之後
威魔擴大了
他還是用很小的部位去做試單
那當然他那時候有科普一下
就是說如果說是
未來量有限的時候
他其實是需要一次下比較多單的
去測試一下市場會怎麼反應
那這就是TO的話
好
那接著他就是QA的時候
有的人在問他說
那海外商品的話就是
他之前一開始也是做海外的鋼沖的商品
那他就問說
我們什麼波動性跟趨勢性比較建議的
那時候他說以前的話是他就是做清源油
那他覺得現在波動跟趨勢比較好的
他覺得是黃金
那小頭像小頭說的是小娜
等於是這類的商品都會有比較大的波動跟趨勢
其實黃金在
大家在YouTube頻道小時候其實講
大概在一兩個月前講過黃金這件事情
那現在已經又太創新高了
其實就是所謂的趨勢跟市場就主流在哪邊
現在市場趨勢就是AI啊 黃金啊
然後科技股
這種情況下就可以去重重去找到獲利的機會
那接著那時候他講有一句話
小時候那時候蠻有感覺的
然後也有問了一下自己
他就說他那時候
一開始剛進市場的時候
他就在找無敵的聖杯
他整天在床上都想說
這隻行情為什麼會上漲
他想要去破解這個行情
他說十多年後他會對
十多年前的那個他講說
其實這是所謂的沒有任何一個
指標或者是
關鍵的一個系統可以去破解所有的行情
那很多時候看到這句話
看到這張影片的時候
會在 沉思
我在想說 那 十多年前的我
我會怎麼去跟現在
就是我現在如果遇到十多年前的我
會怎麼去提點他
那時候我想說
一開始可能就想說
可能是過去的重大虧損的時候
會想要跟他說
就是 欸不要施信封
哈哈 之類的
或者是 欸不要太鑽牛角尖
可是 我後來想來想
也許 十年前多的我
當時我們剛進行市場的那個我
他其實就是需要這些市場的歷練
去讓他深刻的去記憶到
尊重市場這件事情
其實一開始大家交易的時候
總是會有順風順水的時候
怎麼做折斷的時候
但是這過程中
你去遭遇到比如說像今年四月
或者是像2018、2022年
你在多頭市場上去遭遇的一個
突然性的利空跟一個長期的利空走勢的時候
你才能去了解到怎麼去應對這個市場
所以其實我會對十多年前的我跟他講說
你就放手去做
因為你是卓越的
我可能直接講這句話
我不是跟他講話就是
你那個地方可以怎麼做
因為交易沒有對錯
只有透過不同的不停的交易
我們去累積經驗
然後我們成為更好的人
所以這個過程其實
在十多年前的我的話
他也是必備的
一些重大的虧損或一些重大的失控狀況
也是必備的
你才會去成功到現在這個更沉穩的自己
更好的自己
所以就是為了遇見更好的自己
所以我們會有更多的各種歷練
好
所以最後他就講到說
撐著的不是毅力也不是努力
而是那份最單純的喜愛
找回交易最純粹的快樂
那我覺得這句話也是對小周也是很有感觸的
因為其實小周看過很多的成果交易
一樣也是有這個樂在其中
也許樂在其中的過程中
你並沒有辦法馬上得到結果
馬上拿到獲利
但是這個過程中
你享受在其中的時候
行情因為你經歷過的行情越來越多
那你的心境就會
也會上喜喜喜喜喜馬
也會經歷過自己擅長的跟不擅長的
最終你就會去收斂出
屬於你的交易的策略跟交易的手法
那這過程中你從中得到快樂
而不是取決於賺不賺錢
取決於這交易的品質跟你喜愛這個市場
你想要去在這個市場上交易的一個過程
那你就可以去
在這個市場上真正找到屬於你的
的交易的密碼
所以他講說
交易沒有名牌的話
只有對市場無止盡的體解
以及對螢幕背後那個對手的傳聞
這是很有趣的
一旦交易的行情裡面的時候
不是只有K棒
如果只有K棒那有多無聊
如果說K棒的漲跌
跟一些什麼上下引線
你去傳謀背後
不管是你是做多的時候
你的對手是做空的人
或者是
當你的一些消息面放出來的時候
你會知道說
那這些消息面會去怎麼引導行情
那一樣啊
有個題材出現的時候
這個題材出現的時候
相關類股到底有沒有去做反應
那當市場還沒有察覺這件事情的時候
是不是就是你切入的時候
那你可以去慢慢去把它加入關注的自選股
然後等它真的發動的時候
你是第一時間就找到這樣
像最近的那個金寶嘛
一樣啊
金寶那時候就是在古期
一開始亮的先出來了
大概前兩三天就出來了
所以今天就是
期貨一開盤的時候開四盤
然後現貨開盤就擋停了
所以就是等於是
這過程中你必須去先關注到一些
可能性的時候你去把它做關注
加入自選股
所以
另外他講說
交易最好玩的地方是在於
你永遠都可以挑戰比你更強大的存戰
我覺得
這句話也是滿Alpha的
欸 怎麼叫Alpha
Alpha就是所謂的頂尖的交易人
Alpha跟Beta
就所謂的
今天你在這個市場上
下一步是什麼
因為有很多更多更強的人可以去
讓你去挑戰
所以等於就是很興奮的
行情各種有不同的走勢
然後你可以去怎麼去跟它的搏鬥
然後你從中去得到成長
那是我覺得是在
交易金融市場當時最迷人的地方
好 那
最後他講到說他是
未來他要去創造自己的兒童慈善基金會
等於是他說他是一個唯一不用盈利的慈善基金會
那等於是他會把他企劃 企業化經營
然後
然後加了很多那個什麼
就是
把他們的那個
社工高薪水
就是等於是根據等級去分他們的薪水
就等於是
他覺得傳統的社工就是因為薪水比較低
所以他容易留10歲的時候
人才就很難保留
所以他想要去進行科技公司一樣去進行慈善
然後聘請最優秀的專業正攻
所以
這時候就說提供大家一個
之後巨人節如果舉辦自己的蛇叢基金會
大家可以大力的贊助
我覺得這也是
就是所謂的
最安穩做慈善的一個方式
那我覺得也是
小時候就是在巨人節這邊大講說看到的
他是一個很誠懇很實在的人
他講什麼有什麼就是講什麼
那他的願景的話我覺得也是
在交易界裡面的話也是大家的願景
就是所謂的 你有賺到錢玩之後
你去做一些慈善幫助更多的人
好
所以就是因為那個版權的部分
你沒辦法播那個周湯豪哥啦
所以就是如果說你想要去鎖取一些片段的話
你可以去加入小周的LINE 打錄114
那有一段影片是來自於巨人節IG的限動
就是小周也沒有去錄還是什麼的
就是轉速成GiG上面的現場的一些花絮跟影片
接著如果說你還沒有加入群域小周這邊的話
我建議你可以去線上開戶10分鐘
我們可以去獲得群域的公術交易系統
還有我們交易中司的影音檔
包括阿羅密達文西自由的
還有跟小周兩小時一對一教學
可以去幫你看一下你的交易的邏輯
跟你的交易的風格跟交易的系統
所以我們還會有客戶專屬的金融潮盤特訓班
還有一些交易紀錄的見證
如果你在交易上的話
你覺得有點孤單
然後你找不到朋友可以去討論的時候的話
歡迎你線上開戶10分鐘交戶小周這邊
我們有一個大環境這邊
大家可以持續做學習
持續做增進
然後也會有
大家也會互相分享一些心得
那我覺得是一個小周的
進入這個行業的一個初衷
就所謂的我想要有一群人
我們可以一起往前走
而不是所謂的
膽打獨鬥
或者是所謂的
很多人講說 靈和遊戲是我就是賺你錢
沒有 其實大家可以去
在這個市場上可以大家都賺錢的
那這就是講Alumi之前的那個
交易框架的影音檔
然後這個是我自己設計的就是可以去統計
勝率盈虧比跟期望值的Excel
這樣子 那你去認識你的交易的財報跟交易的檢討
好 然後我們來看一下大家有什麼問題
希望小周能持續了 你也只愛共...
感謝健學
林先生晚上好
Brian晚上好
那今天的話就是
也一樣跟周大朝一樣
祝大家2026年的話都可以去順勝利利的
然後我們就是所謂的
健健康康平平安安然後賺大錢
如果有什麼法闪的推幣可以再
還是去除了我一定知道
在這邊
2026年的
剛開始的202年所以希望請問
不要感謝
都會很順利祝大家
祝大家
祝大家 good life